several 80 characters and in the HBO
series it's a little more blatant I was
wondering is there a purpose that you
did for making these characters there
was a disincentive is their purpose that
I had to make encourage gay well I
noticed that there are gay people in the
world
[Applause]
so I I thought I should pursue in my
world too there are certain gay
characters in history at least allegedly
you know first we don't you can look at
English history well you know Alexander
the Great Richard the lion-hearted
edward ii ii all of these are considered
gay by some parlors and others to scoot
that say they're not gay it's of which
we can't actually look into their
bedrooms we'll probably never know the
truth of that although i think the
evidence on some of those is fairly
convincing but you know i did want to
include the the full range of humanity
within the books including the few ring
the full range of sexual preferences and
sexes of important part of the books I
mean history those men I mean if indeed
they were gay it had a significant
effect on history and it has some one
significant effect in the events of my
book not that it always will but for
every date character you're afraid of
course to renovate amorous when you met
Renee to be open your other eight
characters in there and I have treated
it fairly subtly perhaps to some leaves
of some people seem to have missed it
entirely
when HBO made it quickly I got some
brief odd litters people said HDFS moved
your story think of these straight
characters why don't you stop them all
right
they really I'm a 3l isn't isn't
constricted to the viewpoint structure
than I am you know I only show you what
a viewpoint character is present for it
field shows you any character you want
to so we're seeing that the renomii and
Laura scheme majority would see scenes
between Varys Littlefinger either which
is uh is a viewpoint character that I
could not possibly have dramatized in
the books you know unless I have someone
listening from behind the tapestry or
something
but I don't wanna let them that's the
difference between television of novels
they're opening up opening up the thing
it's interesting that I have gotten a
number of a number of letters almost all
of them from women demanding well
requesting lightly requesting suggesting
that they would like my mail email sex
seems to be more explicit
[Applause]
I've taken that under advisement
we should know we shall see